all right Gertie last time I saw you I
was talking to you at the draft and we
had one specific mission
okay what was the combo what's what's
going on so you've seen some of the
little posts you had on the story and
stuff like that but yeah no first DM you
just said welcome home and yeah I said
Thank you so yeah so first step to being
best friends I love it
so tell me just your initial thoughts
about Toronto the city had you ever been
there before the draft process
not before the draft process my first
time was you know going through that
pre-draft where I worked out for
I think I was there like two probably
two or three days so so the city a
little bit but
um after the draft I was there for about
a week so good little time but back in
September I'll be I'll be back for sure
yeah I mean Toronto's truly one of my
favorite cities like
people are so nice the food is really
really good and there's just always
something to do so when you go and
you're like figuring out where you want
to live you can't really go wrong it
really is a great City what do you think
the team saw and you specifically that
could help them win
um first of all uh the kind of thing
they're trying to address was shooting
um I take a lot of pride in that
um that's why I do my best in you know
off the court you know in practice and
just being as prepared as I can be and I
think I think I'd try to let them know
throughout the pre-draft process was I
was coming in with the mindset of
um trying to make an instant impact with
that preparation you know building my
confidence and kind of doing what I did
when I got into high school and then
went to hit the ground running at Kansas
and just trying to maintain that
consistency and doing that here and what
did you think about the talent on the
Raptors before you were picked to be
there exciting you know seeing a lot how
they played in on the freedom that they
play with and just get up and down the
court they play a fun way and with the
new coaching staff and them for the
first time too is been amazing you know
a guy's like like Scotty with that
personality on the team too is what I
look forward to yeah maybe some tick
tocks in our future
you have a few Summer League games under
your belts just from what you've
experienced so far what do you
anticipate being the biggest learning
curve that you will have fixed before
the season begins
I think just getting the flow of
everything it's not I don't know if
there's really a specific thing as of
right now but they're obviously more
that will come along with it but yeah
just the first two games we played today
I'm just getting under my belt and just
getting the flow of playing in kind of
the open space of an NBA floor you know
a lot more you know open open spots to
kind of just play basketball in general
and just learn learn along you know as
the game goes okay well honestly warning
for everybody watching this is not going
to be a very serious show because I have
so many questions to ask you that are
based on very unserious things okay
beginning with your suit I still love it
I need like a deep dive on whose idea
was it to wear the red Dorothy sparkly
suit why you didn't wear the matching
pants I need the full rundown on the
look yeah so first of all I mean simple
I was going on with Dolce Gabbana
they're setting it all up so shout out
them but it was really I saw some ideas
of it and kind of the sparkly actually
it was a full Studio like you said the
pants too yeah so I was like I mean I
caught my eye so I wanted to get that
and
um founded the pants might not have fit
too well it saved me in the end because
I think it would have been way too much
or the black fans kind of settled it
down but
um yeah it was I talk about a lot of I
was going to be the the ones who I'm
probably gonna wear once in my life so I
might yeah go out there and then once I
came in and saw the saw the red and I'm
kind of
um tied that back into the Dorothy story
of her slippers back at Kansas and
Wizard of Oz and all that stuff so made
kind of a HomeTown thing now you show
you so right like yeah so just chest is
out under an injustice
the jacket never came off yeah oh you
said maybe the after party it didn't
happen
I saw in the mirror so no it was just
the rectangle of yeah the little red but
no I love it because you know in 20
years people are going to look back at
your photo
and see the suit what do you want them
to say about your look that night when
we're looking back on it years to come
yeah I don't know if it's very Timeless
or stuff like that so yeah one of those
things when I look back into like kind
of when you look at what the 2003 draft
of LeBron and yeah see a lot of that
stuff and when they're writing them
zeros out of 10 and stuff wrong little
red carpet I'll probably get some of
those yeah
they'll remember it so that's what that
was my goal absolutely I mean I think if
we're talking about some of the more
memorable fits yours is up there exactly
and that is an accomplishment within
itself
um can't lie yesterday I was in a very
deep Grady dig deep dive on Tick Tock I
think I have seen every single video
would you consider yourself a tick
shocker
I guess on social media yeah yeah I mean
you're very good yeah in an interview
that you did with slam you were talking
about social media and how you kind of
separate basketball from social media
because you view it as a bit of an
escape what did you mean by that I think
just when you have the understanding
that it can be negative and it can be a
distraction and trying to stay away from
that is what I try to maintain through
it all because I mean obviously I'm
going to keep the main thing the main
thing and that's the basketball and
Hoops so
um but when I get away from that outside
of practice is where I can kind of
yeah on an escape of
um taking the stress off of just the
constant grind of everything and kind of
watch funny videos make funny videos and
just you know make people laugh is what
I like to do I like making people happy
so how does your personality bleed into
your Encore Persona or do you keep those
separated as well
um it's separate in in the way of
just like one act on Tick Tock it's more
of a goofy moves and stuff like that but
on the core obviously I'm gonna be
dancing
it's like one of those things where it
does bleed through a little of just my
motion with the game because when I'm
either smiling or like yelling after a
big time play it's it's one of those
things that keeps basketball fun and
that's why I started playing when I was
little because I have so much fun with
it and I'm never going to let that kind
of go away and I'm gonna be myself on
the court you know and gig so I didn't
start like yelling trying to get the
crowd happy and
um that's when best was most fun for me
so much yeah do that I love that because
you know I think that a lot of guys as
they continue playing it becomes a job
the joy can sometimes leave what makes
you so sure that for you this will
always be something that is a place of
Happiness I'm just what I was talking
about just being myself through
everything and
um kind of like my two older brothers
watch a lot of them and their teams
growing up and kind of see whether some
of their teammates they have that like
Stone Face where they're kind of show no
emotion through it all and
um
I don't know I just not very
approachable when you kind of you go
watch their games and stuff like that so
I never want to be like that I just
wanted to be myself I keep saying it but
be myself through it all and
um when I'm having fun playing
basketball it just keeps me going and
um makes it where I'm you know not
getting tired of it or anything like
that so I'll never get to that point if
I'm being myself so when you think about
the first moment that you picked up a
basketball what is that
probably the backyard
um with my three other siblings
um we just had like this like concrete
slab my dad just putting like the whole
yard just put a slab of on concrete and
a goal and I just remember after dinner
um we'd eat dinner and then go out there
play for a couple hours and then like
watch a TV show and then go to bed and
yeah that was kind of like our schedule
routine every night so I just remember
that and the Joy from I have from that
from my family yeah so it was never that
you grew to love basketball I was always
just a part of everything that you did
for sure you instantly had a connection
with it yeah huge Sports family so yeah
when were you able to beat your brothers
are you the oldest youngest where are
you there yeah I'm the youngest of the
four so okay oh I got beat up a lot all
that stuff I probably didn't win
anything until around like third grade I
want like a ping pong game and then
start doing that ping Punk and that's
when I started beating them consistently
and then yeah turned to the core and on
the field or baseball or whatever but so
third grade it was beating them in ping
pong and basketball like everything just
flipped over there third grade
basketball okay high school and college
yeah
High School year then then you knew yeah
okay what did you pick up from your
brothers from the court
um I think through them not letting me
win yeah it was that frustration when I
was little that just made me hate losing
so I think the competitive Spirit was
definitely built there
um
I think the biggest advice I get from
them too like still to this day is just
the comparison stuff like don't don't
compare like yourself to anyone and I
see that through social media nowadays
more than ever yeah I'm with say I I get
my grind in for the day I get my work
and you know I'm happy with it when I go
on social media and see someone's
highlights and if I'm not understanding
that like that's their best thing that
they posted I'm comparing what I did
that no one saw to what the world's
seemed and it's kind of like
um a negative thing but understanding
that and just knowing to just stay in
your lane focus on your work and that's
what they remind me of a lot how have
you been able to do that though because
I think that people your age
specifically social media has been a
part of everything that you have been
doing like probably ever since you can
remember so that comparison has become
kind of built into the way that you
think about life so how have you been
able to separate those
um as I was talking about earlier of
keeping the main thing the main thing
yeah um that's my dad's biggest advice
too is focusing getting the first things
done first
um in the morning like early in the day
of getting your work done and then when
you want to watch like when I was when
you watch TV or a movie or I'm going
with your friends it was like what you
did in the morning got it done and then
you have the rest of the day I'm opened
up to do that and I'm kind of taking
that mentality of what I do with that
stuff of
um just focused on what I need to do I'm
getting my kind of routine for the day
and then when I have that time where I
can go and Tick Tock or whatever maybe I
have that kind of free space to do that
okay amazing so on the court obviously
everybody talks about your shooting
ability can you be the next great NBA
shooter that's my goal you know I take a
lot of pride in that
um yeah I'm a focus for sure on my
shooting and I'm just being consistent
with that but I'm excited with I'm going
to this MBA level of just open space of
the floor I was talking about earlier of
um give me that area to kind of show new
things that I did as much in college but
just using that Florida to my advantage
and getting the spaces where I can shoot
a high volume of shots and eventually
try to achieve my goal of you know being
that where people can think of a great
shooter and think of my name yeah you
know some people they work on it and
they become really good Shooters some
people always they naturally had it in
them where do you fall
I think I've been well like a I would
say three point because I'm a little bit
like when I was little I was yeah
getting used to my shooting and
um that was for sure for my mom um she
played Iowa State Pro in Japan
um so she kind of she was the basketball
side of our family and then my dad was
football baseball but yeah my mom
definitely taught me the mechanics of
kind of the high release and start off
like a little ball when I was little
just to like so if I'm shooting three
threes at a young age I'm not messing up
my mechanics and stuff like that so she
had good advice with that and
um but on that just being consistent
with it and that kind of translates when
I was older I just kept kind of shooting
habits now I know that you really like
Larry Bird and Steph Curry in terms of
your kind of best Shooters but I want
you to pick attributes from your
favorites we're gonna build like the
greatest shooter okay so we're gonna
choose someone's release similar to
someone's balance someone foot someone's
footwork and we'll build the best person
okay let's start with their release
who's would you pick release
probably Larry Bird or kind of Reggie
Miller combined higher releases so okay
I can't really block it as well okay
what about footwork
Clay Thompson okay what about his he's
always his foundation is always just
solid you know he's coming off screens
he's always just facing the basket never
like off balance where he's can miss it
easy so he's always just I don't know
trying to straight up and down with the
goal okay I feel like I might know the
answer to this one but range
uh best off the dribble but you can't
say anyone you've already said
um
Paul George I like the way he's just so
versatile with you know his height and
his size but the way he can still handle
the ball and you know get up shots you
see all these videos of his open runs
and I mean games in general not just how
he gets to his spots is when I try to
take a lot of that stuff and utilize
that and practice and stuff like that
pretty a shot
hmm
there's some good ones
I think
I know Klay Thompson it looks like it's
just like the same every time yeah I
watch a lot of that just his mechanics
it's just I'm just squaring just
straight so you can't really see any bad
clips of him like shooting weird so yeah
okay what would you take from Grady dick
but my release point and just the
quickness quickness of it okay I love
that I think that that's probably uh
good good
is something like maybe doing a
Three-Point Contest is that a goal of
yours um
you're like sign me up you guys hear it
he's ready to go he's ready to do it
okay so you mentioned Paul George and I
have to ask you this because it seems
like your generation of hoopers love
Paul George obviously we heard what
Brandon Miller said we heard Kyan
Anthony talking about him now you Paul
George is fantastic big Paul George fan
but why do you think he resonates with
you all so much
I think it's just what the game has come
to
um obviously he's not like the center
where you see Center shooting threes but
he I mean you've got like six ten and
he's the way he gets to his spots and
um the game has developed so much where
it's guys with that position position
list really where they can be that size
and still shoot it at a high rate and
um he can do that but also just the way
he handles the ball like a guard is not
a lot of people are like that so I think
that's what a lot of guys see nowadays
yeah no I like it because that's not
what some of the older players would say
when you're asking
ordered some things but he is very
popular amongst you but I get it because
his versatility is kind of unmatched
when you're thinking about players
around the league
um I read something really cool that
when you were at Kansas in your dorm
move in in June you found a note that
was left by a former player and it said
whoever takes over this room go be great
yeah if you were leaving a note for
someone at Kansas
City you did yeah because it was so I
stayed in the same room obviously so it
was from ochai
um he left my note and then Hunter
Dickinson's going into Kansas now
um big time player and so the coaches
want to be and he's my boy too so I left
alone in the same spot it was kind of
funny okay has he found it yeah you got
it what did the notes say I'd like kept
the same thing I kept that up yeah put a
little play on words on our last names
trying to be funny but then I said be
great I
was yeah he knows
secret he knows wait did you ever talk
to Ojai about the note was he the first
person that had done that or has this
kind of been a thing that's been going
on that you just didn't know about not
of none of my knowledge I think that you
kind of started it and yeah I talked to
him after I mean because we're close so
yeah thanked him for it and so that was
cool
um yeah I guess we're kind of passing on
now yeah yeah it's super special too
because at a place like Candace there's
obviously so many expectations it's
always that you need to win so seeing
that how did it help set the foundation
for what you wanted to do in your time
there yeah I think it was great I mean
it was one of those things where's my
dream school going into it I knew it was
going to come with it of me being the
hometown kid and
um I mean the pressure I talked about
that just being an excitement you know
the fans there and the people from kids
are excited to see a HomeTown kid go out
there and
um play for Kansas so I took that in and
just
um played my best and played throughout
the year and just play basketball at the
end of the day and
um I think you know when you're playing
the island Field House
not like any other place so right
unfortunately in that aspect I feel like
if you can play in an environment like
that then
um it kind of helps you go into some of
these NBA arenas so for you what does it
mean to be great to be great
um just a legacy I feel like is the
first one that comes up and when you
think of a great player you think of you
know what they did but more importantly
like how they
um just wear themselves throughout
throughout it all
um how they carry themselves on and off
the court because I mean you're gonna
see their play but I think what's going
to stick with a person even more is you
know how they treated other people so I
think that's really the character that
comes with it that's why I try to
remember if you want to be my goofy self
off the court it's just just making
people happy at the end of the day yeah
makes you laugh like who are your
favorite comedians what do you do when
you want to laugh
because I feel like you're making
everyone else laugh yesterday
um we were doing the USC thing at UFC
fight my first one and
um the thing with Las Vegas and USC
stuff is just random celebrities all
around yeah so I'm just in the hotel
room
um out watching Theo Von he's a comedian
yeah
it's just so Random these little events
were kind of you know on the stage you
just meet random people it's cool though
yeah are you like uh are you a Drewsky
fan like who's your internet comedian
favorites yeah
all the live Instagram stuff like that
yeah it's so funny because I was
actually just having this conversation
like now when you have the internet and
you're funny the world really is so open
to you and you can just build careers
off of being yourself and I'm sure
people around you have told you this but
who you are really is your biggest asset
because you do bring joy and you make
people comfortable and you have this big
personality outside of basketball which
will set you up for so many things that
you can't even imagine yet so I just
hope that you always keep this about
yourself where you are you and happy and
smiling all the time because it is
incredibly uh refreshing
um in that same article that I was
reading I saw that you really like Rod
wave and the lyrics play the hand you're
dealt is something that you run through
your mind a lot why is that phrase
important in your life that's very
important because I mean people are
gonna all be themselves in their own
ways and you know God is giving you
different talents that a lot of people
don't have they may have that you you
don't have you're gonna have something
that they don't have but it's just I
mean plan ahead and your adult kind of
just means like I'm doing the best that
you have and I mean if in a basketball
way for me if shooting was kind of that
one thing that I built then that's what
I was doing I guess I'm gonna just be
consistent with and try to build
throughout my life as a basketball
player yeah and I know that when you
were seven years old your mom was
diagnosed with colorectal cancer and in
that article your dad said I think that
molded Grady and some different ways to
not take things for granted what do you
think your dad meant by that I think
I've just
before you know she was diagnosed our
whole family I was young so I didn't
really understand like the gravity of it
but just it really put in things in
their perspective of you know what she
did for her family and what she she does
um
all that stuff teaches me Sports and
just everything for our family and so
um when that was kind of away for the
time she was diagnosed and I'm battling
that is where I saw kind of hold our
family
um but it was really filled with us
coming together in the community of
Wichita and that's why I always talk
about what my platform is going to go
back to that commercial community and
just Kansas in general but
um you learn through that kind of time
and when she was cancer-free just her
getting back to it and yeah it was the
best time so good and I love a lot of
your love for basketball is tied to your
love for your mom so what has she just
meant to your life I mean everything I
mean they're out here watching the game
serving my dad so they don't miss a
single game I think the one game they
missed in college was in a way game at
West Virginia but I know they were there
it was
some away game it might have been like
I'm thinking they've been there
it was a summer away game but that was
like they've never missed it maybe one
away potentially
yeah yeah
foreign country but no they're there too
so yeah they missed one game but other
than that I mean they they're so
supportive and that's my support system
than my family so amazing okay so what's
the plan with Toronto do you think
they'll be able to make a bunch with
circling the ones on the calendar that
are musties how are you guys gonna do
that yeah they'll make it out to some
but you know as I said at the same time
I told him I don't know about moving out
is the right choice just yet yeah they
like stay there guys I'll come back
here's my chance to grow my own way for
sure um no I always have a little extra
room for them whenever they come up kind
of like a little Airbnb for them so it'd
be that whenever they want to watch some
games but yeah I'm a girl alone right
now so what are you feeling about you
know going to this new city and really
establishing yourself there being away
from your family I'm excited you know
obviously being away from them is is a
good thing just growing wise but I mean
with basketball I don't
haven't been set just living in Kansas
because you know basketball makes you
travel everywhere so yeah um just doing
that and I'm gonna have a support system
whatever I need but I'm extremely
excited to be in Toronto because I was
there for the couple weeks when I after
we got drafted so I'm just seeing the
city and just the genuine people just
making it feel right at home
um facilities knew the coaches and just
mean everything for the first time
putting the faces behind the names has
been a great and great time and I'm
excited to get back out there amazing
okay last view for you what personal
goals do you have next season
um as a per like me for is just making
an instant impact
um personally I'm just trying to go in
and
um I mean it sounds cheesy but just
doing what the coach needs really
because my mindset's always to whatever
the team needs I'm gonna go out there
you know give them 110 at it um and then
as a team
um just get back to winning culture
because that's what they have there and
so
um anything we do you know in Toronto
I'm learning quickly is that people are
going to support it all the way yeah
crazy this person in that country so
yeah so
whatever I do just give it 110
everything
the Raptors fan base is like one of the
more supportive of them all like
definitely probably top five they love
their Afters there so you're gonna feel
that very quickly and I'm sure you
already have
um what have you just picked up from the
coaches and staff just in terms of what
you feel like they want your role to be
next season I'm just stepping in and
like I said earlier just give him 110
anything that they asked me to do um
with Coach coach Darko coming in
um I was talking about he's one of the
most knowledgeable guys that I'm
starting to learn more about and
um out here just learning from him and
um seeing things in his perspective is
crazy because I've had some great
coaches in the past with
um coach Luke in high school and winning
um two of the coaches of the years and
then Bill self Hall of Fame coach but
then you get coach Darko and his
knowledge of the game is unlike anyone
else so I'm learning from him in a
couple of my workouts that I did after
the draft and just seeing new things in
my game that can get better at is what's
going to be super helpful and beneficial
for me what makes you excited out
playing with Scotty
uh just the excitement that we can bring
no to the people there and and just what
we can do with that kind of duo with
each other of what we can do on the
court and
um use that to our advantage of how we
can play and have fun doing it I mean
the personalities are there that are
going to kind of shine out so
um just going in there you know me and
him are going to be ourselves and just
have fun doing whatever we do I love it
well I'm so excited to watch you play
gotta go to Toronto go do some Tim
Hortons have you had it yet I know it is
okay that has to be stop number one you
gotta go to SoDo you got to do all the
fun things I'm super excited for you
you're going to love it I'm sure I'll
see you at a game but thank you so much
for your time excited to watch you as a
raptor thanks for having me thanks Katie
thank you